on va prendre la direction de de luine à
présent Lucas où la population s'est
mobilisée ce weekend contre la fermeture
hivernale de la piscine et oui on ne
pourra peut-être pas y faire voguer nos
petits bateaux cet hiver c'est une
mesure qui a été votée le 11 décembre
par les élus métropolitains ils actent
ainsi pour les prochaines années la
fermeture annuelle de l'établissement
pendant 3 mois plusieurs raisons sont
avancées une faible fréquentation sur
cette période une grande consommation de
gaz pour chauffer les bassins extérieurs
et bien sûr une volonté de réaliser des
économies en effet en 2020
l'établissement coûterait plus de 800000
€ pour une ouverture s 12 mois une
décision remise en cause et que ne
comprennent pas les
usagers on veut nager même en février
c'est ce qu'expliquait ce dimanche la
centaine d'habitants massés devant la
piscine de luine et parmi eux les plus
impactés par cette décision de fermeture
hivernale prise par la métropole les
usagers de l'établissement ça condamne
les nageurs du club qui ont des très
bons résultats au département en région
à devoir s'organiser autrement ou à
renoncer à faire partie de ce club là
l'aquagym pour nous B ça nous fait du
bien on en a besoin moi depuis que je
fais de l'aquagym je n'ai plus mal au
dos j'ai des problèmes de tendon
d'Achile donc il y a des sports que je
ne peux pas pratiquer et en piscine
c'est moins moins violent pour moi donc
ça m'aide aussi à faire un peu de
rééducation une fois qu'on y a goûté et
ben c'est comme le chocolat on peut plus
arrêter on a accro à la piscine donc
pour soutenir notre piscine faut venir
en plus d'une baisse générale de
fréquentation des bains on craint ici de
porter préjudice aux enfants dans leur
apprentissage de la natation mais le
risque est aussi de freiner dans leur
développement les clubs implantés à
luine l'utilité c'est déjà les
apprentissage de natation aujourd'hui on
déplore des noyades en masse sur les
bords de mer dans les équipements
sportif et aujourd'hui on régresse dans
ces bases n on a la particularité d'être
club de natation et de développer le
sauvetage l'objectif c'est de mettre en
place un pôle de jeune sauveteur donc on
a bah du sauvetage avec de la
compétition de l'apprentissage euh mais
aussi on va plus loin savoir se sauver
savoir sauver les autres et là ça nous
met un un réel frein à tous ce
développement les 3 mois de fermeture
ont été votés par les élus
métropolitains dans le but de réduire
les dépenses de la collectivité face à
la hausse des prix de l'énergie pourtant
pour le maire d'autres solutions sont
envisageables il y a beaucoup de travail
à faire pour essayer de montrer queil y
a d'autres solutions et j'ai conseillé à
mes collègues de travailler sur
peut-être d'autres systèmes peut-être
mettre en place des pompes à chaleur
peut-être regarder si au niveau du
solaire il y a pas des évolutions à
faire je pense qu'on va travailler
là-dessus le but est trouver une
solution dans l'intérêt des populations
des nageurs les usagers ont grand espoir
de faire revenir la métropole sur cette
décision d'autres actions sont déjà en
préparation